that's your classic game day breakfast
your carbs fiber your protein you throw
a shot of brandy in there you'll be
ready to play in the ice bowl i don't
eat beets
never have
never will
when you were two you ate a dime and a
butterfly now your body is a temple he
can eat a protein bar in the car we
still have to pick up some players that
live far away gloria this is not okay
it's legal they have p.o boxes in the
district and besides everybody bends the
rules i swear the goalie from the other
team has been my uber driver boy i'm
trying to get the kid to eat his
vegetables i could use a little support
why aren't you dressed you're supposed
to referee two games today i told you i
don't want to do that i got my boxing
match tonight besides those ref outfits
are stupid walk it off you're fine move
the joke you're not hearing that
hey are you ridley i'm ref in the one
o'clock game hey do i get my voucher for
a hot dog before or after oh
hey you got your whistle oh damn i
forgot it late and no whistle where's
your respect for the game on a football
field somewhere hey what do you say i
borrow yours are you kidding i just lost
six weeks of school to mono you're on
field four
all right let's get this over with you
are the referee for my game you don't
know anything about soccer take that up
with the lady who forced me into this
okay purple let's go jonathan clyde up
front lucas dylan chad in the back and
stefan in goal i'm guessing that estefan
is the kid who lives out of the district
his legs are hairier than mine and i
think he was wearing a wedding ring
let's get this party started rookie
okay they won't start unless you use the
whistle
whistle
whistle
glide it's open yes
whistle no goal purple offside offside
are you blind he's right free kick for
red right where the ball is yes free
kick for red right where the ball is and
whistle
for the first time in weeks gloria had
to listen to me
i was in charge ridley said so
oh yes coach you're running up the score
you got to sub in some of your weaker
players how about this kid with the neck
pillow it's usually a tip-off i am not
running off the score i'm winning you
either make the substitution or you are
leaving my
field that's it whistle you're out of
here
doesn't frighten me
how about that a little bit
okay we need to talk you bet we need to
talk i was out of bounds throwing you
out of that game you bet you were out of
bounds throwing me out of that game but
it was all my fault jake you bet he was
all my fault jay zumbo's bunny me okay
so we both like to be in charge but when
it comes to joe can we both be on the
same page like this morning when i was
trying to get him to eat his vegetables
back me up
i knew i should have thrown away those
beets stupid what am i for
i guess we're not setting a very good
example exactly when we say no to each
other he thinks he can say no to us yeah
like for his homework his bedtime or
something important like eating those
nutritious
whistles
[Music]
you